fish used to be the main dish for
yemenis
prices at this auction at the Central
Fish Market in Eden are too high for
most people to afford
able
let some of the officials come here and
see what we are dealing with they need
to figure out a way to lower these
prices your average citizen cannot buy
any fish
Yemen's currency has lost value by 400
to reducing the purchasing power of
people
fishermen here also blame uncontrolled
fishing by commercial vessels off their
Coast
those catching fish risk their lives
going further out to sea according to
rights organizations many have been
killed by the Saudi UAE Coalition who
have raged a war against the country
since 2014.
they're insane we can't buy meat now we
can't afford
this this so wrong
authorities with the UN recognized
government in Yemen have blamed the
situation partly on exports to
neighboring countries but have now
implemented an export ban
also mentioned that there are brokers
who come to the ports and take large
quantities of fish the minute the ship
docks and they immobilizes sales when it
comes to the local market unfortunately
the fish we have don't go to the average
yemeni consumer but they end up being
sold for higher prices outside the
governor
many question whether the authorities
can enforce a ban on exports leaving
fish caught by yemenis Out Of Reach for
most families
I said Big Al Jazeera